HAVING ARRIVED WILL CALL THIS
MEETING TO ORDER.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN THE AS
A SUB I'M NOT SEEN QUORUM
MEMBERS PLEASE.
JOIN US HERE ATTRITION SOONEST
AVAILABLE OPPORTUNITY.
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH ITEM TO
WHAT YOUR AGENDA EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY GRAY I WILL.
PASSED THE GAVEL TO THE VICE
CHAIR [inaudible]
MR GRAY.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS STAR AB
EIGHT EIGHTY WILL ESTABLISH AN
EFFECTIVE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
FOR THE TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUN.
TO INCREASE THE IMPACT OF GAMING
REVENUES FOR NON GAMING AND
LIMITED GAMING TRIBES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
THE T. NGF WAS INITIALLY CREATED
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE COMPAQ'S
IS AN ADDITIONAL FUND FOR GAMING
REVENUES THAT WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED TO ELIGIBLE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE TROUBLE
COMPAQ'S ARE CURRENT LAW
SPECIFIED.
HOW THESE MUCH NEEDED FUNDS
WOULD BE ADMINISTERED AND
DISPERSED?
AB EIGHT EIGHTY REFLECTS IN PART
FROM TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
FOLLOWING YEARS OF DISCUSSION
FORMAL CONSULTATIONS WITH TRIBAL
LEADERS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS BY BOTH G. O.
COMMITTEES.
UNDER THE BILL DISTRIBUTIONS
WILL BE MADE BY TRIBAL LEADERS
UPON APPLICATION OF ELIGIBLE
TRIBES FOR PURPOSES RELATED TO
SELF GOVERNANCE.
SELF DETERMINATION AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AB EIGHT EIGHT IS A
WELL THOUGHT OUT BILL THAT
MAINTAINS PROPER ADMINISTRATION
CRITERIA TO MEET SEVERAL
IMPORTANT OBJECTIVES THAT WILL
HELP TO IMPROVE THE WELL BEING.
OF CALIFORNIA TRIBES FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
VOTE AND WE HAVE MISTER JOE
DILLON FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
HERE WITH US. TO TESTIFY AS WELL
[inaudible]
DILLON WELCOME.
BUT THINKING CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
VICE CHAIRMAN.
KNOW TIME IS SHORT AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT I THINK
I'LL JUST FOCUS ON ON THE
MANAGER'S EXPAND UPON THIS.
WEEK AND IT HERE ALL DAY WE HAVE
MUCH TIME YES SIR THAT WE'RE NOT
YET IT AMENDMENT SO I THINK FALL
INTO TWO CATEGORIES ONE IS --
TO SPECIFIED THAT THE TRIBAL
ADVISOR A POSITION WHICH IS
CREATED IN THIS BILL --
MUST BE AN ENROLLED MEMBER OF
THAT FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE THINK
THAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO
THAT WAS THE INTENT OF THAT
POSITION.
THIS CLARIFIES THAT A SECOND
CATEGORY IS I JUST THINK TO
CLARIFY THE ROLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
OF THE THE PRIOR LANGUAGES HAVE
APARTMENT FOR REPORT THIS
SPECIFIES THAT THE TRIBAL
ADVISED TO WILL REPORT TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND DESCENDED GEO.
ANNUALLY WITH THEIR THAT ISSUE
SAID THAT IF.
THE COMMITTEE BELIEVES THAT HAD
THROUGH ITS OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY SOME AMENDMENTS
ARE REQUIRED TO SOME OTHER
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
I NEED TO BE ADDRESSED TO CAN DO
SO.
IN ADDITION.
THAT A LANGUAGE REGARD TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS --
WAS CLARIFIED OF TO THAT IT
WOULDN'T BE A CONTINUES TO
PREPARATION BUT THAT IT WOULD BE
A AN ANNUAL APPROPRIATION
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
THERE'S A THE AMENDMENTS HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANY ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THIS IN A POSITIVE SENSE.
ANYBODY WISHING TO ADDRESS THIS
IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
SINGER ó WE DO HAVE A QUESTION
OVER HERE MISS WALDRON.
JUST THIRD CLARIFICATION
QUESTION SO THE TRIBAL ADVISER
IS A MEMBER OF A TRIAL A TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT.
BUT THE MEMBERS OF THE PANEL
APPOINTED MUST BE ELECTED TRIBAL
LEADERS.
HIS THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION SO
THAT THE TRIBAL ADVICE MUST BE
ENROLLED MEMBER NOT NECESSARILY
MEMBER OF A GOVERNMENT.
THAT WE SPECIFIED THAT.
THAT FOR THE INITIAL PROCESS
BECAUSE THE TRIBAL ADVISER WILL
BE WORKING WITH THE PANEL TO
ESTABLISH THE PROCESS TO CREATE
THE FORUMS THE REGULATIONS OR
WHATEVER THE SPEED AND THOSE
INDIVIDUALS MUST BE ELECTED
TRIBAL LEADERS.
BEYOND THAT THE PROCESS FOR
ELECTING THE PANEL WILL BE DONE
THROUGH CONSULTATION WITH ALL
TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS --
PUT IN THE BILL LANGUAGE BECAUSE
THAT REFLECT THE WILL OF THE
TRIBES AND BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THEY COULD --
THROUGH THAT CONSULTATION
PROCESS RETAINER TWEAK YOUR DO
WHATEVER SO WE FELT THAT.
THAT POWER. TO TO TO ENSURE THAT
THE PROCESS HAS LEGITIMACY
SHOULD REST WITH.
THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENT THAT THIS
IS [inaudible] FOR THAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU MISTER
GRAY MISTER DON'T APPRECIATE
THAT PRESENTATION WHEN WE HAVE
THE A QUORUM ESTABLISHED WILL
TAKE THAT BUT A LOT.
MISTER SANTIAGO WERE ACTING AS A
SUB COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW WOULD
YOU LIKE TO COME UP PRESENT AB
[inaudible]
TWELVE SEVENTEEN AIR
IT WOULD.
WITH THE FOR SURE APPRECIATE
BREVITY.
AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN WILL
AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT OF ABC
TISSUE SPECIAL --
ON TH UNTIL GENERAL ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE LICENSE TO HOLLYWOOD
FOREVER CEMETERY IN LOS ANGELES
FOR INDOOR AND OUTDOOR EVENTS.
THIS SCHOOL A LONG WAYS TOWARDS
LIVE IN ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU ARE SO NEVER.
I SEE SOME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND SUPPORT MY
NAME IS G. V. AIRS I REPRESENT
HOLLYWOOD FOREVER CEMETERY.
AND WE APPRECIATE OF MISTER
SANTIAGO FOR OFFERING THIS
DISTRICT BILL.
AND HOLLYWOOD DOES ABOUT NINETY
OF THESE OF AND SO MORE THAN ONE
A WEEK THIS WOULD HELP --
TO WORK FOR THE DEMAND THAT
WHICH THEY HAVE DOWN THERE AND
IN LOS ANGELES.
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY YET PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
NATIONAL REST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT BINGO.
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS MUST GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE THANK
YOU ALL FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I'M FOR VERY FAMILIAR
WITH.
HOW IF EVER AND --
THEY DO A MAGNIFICENT JOB I
THINK CERTAINLY THIS WILL --
IN YOUR WORDS LIVEN IT UP --
BUT I THINK IT IS VERY
APPROPRIATE --
PLEASE A LET TYLER NO OTHELLO
AND I DO SUPPORT THE BILL.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WE ARE ABSENT A
QUORUM AT THE MORE SANTIAGO BUT
ONE MORE MEMBER RIDES AND WE
WILL ESTABLISH THAT QUORUM ANNA
AND MOVE FOR TAKE IF YOU
PRESENTATION.
WELL SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
GRAY HERE BIGELOW.
ACOSTA.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN THEIR BONTA [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOPER HERE DAILY HERE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON [inaudible]
HERE GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER HERE KILEY
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT --
MOST WELCOME WITH REGARDS TO THE
BILL THAT WE JUST HEARD --
WIDE WAS THE CEMETERY HAPPY TO
BE TURNED INTO A WINERY.
THEY DIDN'T WANT ALL THE OLD
WOODEN CASKETS GOES AWAY --
AND WITH THAT MEMBERS WE HAVE A
WITH THAT I MOVE APPROACH.
WE BOTTOM LINE.
IF IT LOADS SO WHERE MOTION THE
SECOND AB EIGHT EIGHTY SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS --
CENTER MEMBERS TO BE CONCURRENT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I GRAY AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN.
BERMAN HIGH BONTA [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON ARE GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER BY JONES SAWYER AYE
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
OKAY WE'VE GOT A MOTION ON ITEM
THREE A BE TWELVE SEVENTEEN WE
HAVE A SECOND.
ON SEARCHES PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATE MEMBERS TO BE CONCURRED
IN.
RIGHT AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BONTA [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON ARE GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER I DON'T SAWYER AYE
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS WALDRON
[inaudible]
WALDRON.
THAT BILLS OUT OKAY MEMBERS WILL
WELCOME A SON MEMBER KALRA OF
HIS PRESENTATION OF ITEM FOR AB.
TWO THOUSAND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURZA SENATE AMENDMENTS
TO ASSEMBLY BILL A TWO THOUSAND
REVISING EXISTING TIED HOUSE
EXCEPTION FOR THAT'S A P. CENTER
HOME TO THE SAN JOSE SHARKS. TO
ALIGN WITH OTHER EXCEPTIONS TO
PROVIDE GREATER.
GREATER FLATLY AT ARMS WHICH IS
A LOT OF AN ARRANGEMENT --
BECAUSE OF THE ASTRONAUTS
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
EXCELLENT CLOSE.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
RICHARD CAST CAN HAPPEN.
WE APPRECIATE THIS.
YES A PIECE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
ENTER GOVERNMENT HAVE THE
SYMPTOMS GOOD GIANTS IN SUPPORT
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
MISTER COOLEY AND SECOND FROM --
REG JONES SAWYER.
SEARCH YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS --
SENATE MEMBERS TO BE CONCURRED
GRAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA YEAH ACOSTA
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BONTA [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON -- I
GIPSON AYE [inaudible]
GLORIA.
COOPER YEAH I JONES SAWYER.
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
I WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
OKAY MEMBERS THAT GOES OUT
REMOVED ITEM ONE OF THE AGENDA
AB SEVEN HUNDRED MISTER JONES
SAWYER PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS THE
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING ACTED VAMPS
IT PROVISIONS FROM ADVERTISING
DISPLAYS LOCATED ON THE PREMISES
OF AN ARENA WHICH HAS BEEN
AUTHORIZED BY LOCAL ORDINANCE
JANUARY.
ONE TWO TWENTY NINETEEN THIS
BILL WOULD EXTEND THE DATE OF
THIS OXIDATION BEGINNER MODE ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ABOUT MISTER
COOLEY THIS BILL WAS BROUGHT TO
ME BY LA FC.
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY JOHN
LATTIMER THAT AMBER IS A RESPECT
OR FBI VOTE.
LA FOOTBALL CLUB IN SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
AND TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING BACK THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
SEEING THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THIS IS --
DO PASSED SENATE MEMBER TO BE
CONCURRED IN --
EXCEPT IT WAS KALRA.
CRANK AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BONTA COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON HI GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER AYE.
JOHN SAWYER AYE KILEY
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT AT THIS TIME
MEMBERS REMOVED ITEM FIVE ON
YOUR AGENDA AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
TWO ALFA SELLING THEIR BAG
RECORD WOULD PLEASE --
MOVE APPROACH PRESENT WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR MICHIGAN SECOND
MISTER DALY [inaudible]
PRESENTATION.
I'LL MAKE THIS QUICK GUIDE AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY TWO UPDATES
TIED HOUSE LOVE.
LAW TO ACCOMMODATE THE
WIDESPREAD USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
TESTIMONY IN SPORT TIM WENT ON
BEHALF OF THE NAPA VALLEY
DINNERS OR SPRINKLE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA HONORABLY HAVE THE
FAMILY WHEN MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING BACK THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
SEEING THAT WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND.
THIS IS US SENATE AMENDMENTS TO
BE CONCURRED IN THAT SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
S. AYE AGUIAR-CURRY WINE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON --
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I JONES SAWYER BY JOHN
SAWYER AYE KILEY.
LACKEY OR LACKEY AYE LOW
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS AYE
WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT AND NOW A
NUMBER SIX ON YOUR PROGRAM
NUMBER ONE IN YOUR HEARTS MISTER
BERMAN PLEASE --
APPROACH AND PRESENT YOUR BILL.
WHAT MORE IS LESSER MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS --
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY NINE IS A
GOOD BILL THAT CREATES PARITY
AMONGST INDUSTRIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
AND WITH ME IS DENNIS LOCAL
REPRESENTING A CALIFORNIA BURIN
BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS GLAD TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL PULL ABOUT THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
MOTION FOR MISTER BIGELOW SECTOR
MRS SALAS.
SENATE MEMBERS WE CONCURRED IN
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN BY BERMAN
AYE BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON --
AYE GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER I DON'T
SAWYER AYE KILEY.
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
THAT GOES OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ONE MINUTE TO ADD
ON AND DIMMER GOING TO REPORT
BACK -- TO
BEFORE FOR DUTY
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THERE ARE PROBABLY.
IS NO ROOM [inaudible]
FOR LIKE WE SOME [inaudible]
OR FOR I KNOW THAT YOU MAKE.
YOU KNOW I I AM PEAK.
I'M PUTTING THE RIGHT
[inaudible]
I LIVE [inaudible]
COOPER ALSO.
AND A LOT.
AND DALY I MESSED UP BY MISS
ADAMS BILL MEASURES.
SO MY YES ON ALL ON ALL.
IT DOESN'T HELP THAT WE ARE.
GOING THAT YOU GOTTA LOOK WHAT
[inaudible]
WHAT?
WELL YOU CAN GET.
WHAT WOULD PAYMENT MISTER?
YEAH EVERYTHING MISS MIGHT NOW
BE OVER ONE OF THE WHOLE. TWENTY
NOT NOT.
I MISS THAT [inaudible]
HARD [inaudible]
THERE.
I VISION OR PUBLIC [inaudible]
ONCE THE WE'RE GOOD COMMITTEE
ADJOURNED